[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
buscarlo en google imaginad que os
tenéis que comprar una casa donde creéis
que es más barata en barcelona o en
miami por si necesitáis alguna pista os
diré que las dos ciudades tienen más o
menos la misma población cuando contamos
con el área metropolitana
ambas ciudades tienen playa y son muy
turísticas además el sueldo medio de
miami es casi el doble que el de
barcelona y la tasa de desempleo es
también muchísimo más baja
dicho esto muchos pensaréis que por
lógica barcelona tiene que ser más
barata que miami verdad pues os
equivocáis las viviendas en barcelona
son un 15% más caras que las de miami si
amigos de visual polític comprar una
casa en españa es una auténtica misión
imposible
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando muchos
las viviendas son caras en todas partes
es verdad pues tenéis razón los precios
de las casas están creciendo en casi
todos los países y esto es sorprendente
si tenemos en cuenta que la tendencia en
el resto de bienes es al contrario os lo
hemos contado mil veces aquí en visual
político la humanidad va mejor
prácticamente hemos erradicado la
desnutrición en el mundo nuestro nivel
de vida es mucho más alto que el de
nuestros abuelos y esto se debe entre
otras cosas a que los productos que
consumimos son más baratos
por ejemplo hace solo 30 años mi padre
tenía que ahorrar el sueldo de un mes
para poder volar de madrid a berlín y
mis abuelos tenían que hacer auténticos
equilibrios financieros para poder comer
todos los días cosas tan comunes en
nuestra dieta diaria como la carne de
pollo o de ternera estaban reservadas
para bodas y grandes eventos por suerte
hoy en día eso es historia sin embargo
la vivienda es el único elemento que no
solo no es más accesible sino que se
está convirtiendo en algo prohibitivo en
muchas partes del mundo
en este vídeo vamos a centrarnos en el
ejemplo de españa porque es donde hemos
encontrado más información pero muchas
de las cosas que vamos a repasar pueden
aplicarse a casi cualquier país porque
la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es por
qué es tan caro comprar una casa hay
alguna forma de solucionar este problema
hoy vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia y por cierto quedaros hasta
el final del vídeo porque tengo una
sorpresa para vosotros
[Música]
del suelo que es lo primero y lo más
importante que necesitamos para
construir una casa
efectivamente el suelo donde vamos a
edificar la verdad pues bien en ese
aspecto
españa tiene la geografía perfecta
hablamos de un territorio enorme
principalmente plano y con muchísimas
zonas despobladas otros países como por
ejemplo países bajos sí que tienen un
auténtico problema de densidad de
población sin embargo españa tiene
espacio de sobra para todos sus
habitantes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ahora bien tener un terreno en propiedad
no significa que podamos usarlo para
construir viviendas por ejemplo en el
año 2011 el 40% del suelo de madrid
estaba considerado como no urbanizable
es decir que el ayuntamiento limita la
edificación en estos territorios en
otras ciudades como por ejemplo málaga
este porcentaje ascendía a más del 70%
y os preguntaréis por qué hay tantísimos
terrenos donde no se puede construir la
respuesta está en los servicios
municipales veréis cuando construimos
una zona residencial
necesitamos poner alcantarillas
electricidad nuevas líneas de autobuses
y por supuesto recogida de basuras y
quién se hace cargo de todos estos
costes
pues efectivamente los ayuntamientos es
decir todos los contribuyentes cuando
pagamos nuestros impuestos dicho de otra
manera si una empresa constructora saca
una promoción de viviendas en las
afueras de madrid y no las consigue
vender todos los madrileños tendrán que
hacerse cargo de los servicios urbanos
de una zona está completamente
despoblada y por eso los ayuntamientos
quieren controlar hasta el más mínimo
detalle de dónde y cómo se expande su
municipio habéis oído hablar alguna vez
de los planes de ordenación urbana pues
bien estos planes son un mapa que saca
un ayuntamiento cada 10 años donde se
especifica en qué zonas se puede
construir y en qué zonas no se puede
construir pero esperad un momento porque
si veis este vídeo desde españa ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando no se supone que
el suelo está liberalizado efectivamente
en el año 1997 el gobierno de josé maría
marcha con una ley que suponía en teoría
la ley
realización del suelo esto significaba
que prácticamente todo el suelo del país
pasaba a ser urbanizable es decir apto
para la construcción de repente todas
las ciudades españolas crecieron y
surgieron montones de nuevas todas las
residenciales y este fue el comienzo de
la burbuja inmobiliaria pero como
decimos muchas veces en visual político
el [ __ ] está en los detalles veréis
hemos dicho que los planes de ordenación
urbana determinan las zonas donde se
puede edificar pero no se quedan ahí
también fijan las condiciones en las que
se puede construir vamos a imaginar que
pedimos un permiso al ayuntamiento de
barcelona- para poder construir un
bloque de pisos en una parcela que
tenemos pues bien el ayuntamiento nos va
a decir que no hay problema pero que
sólo podemos construir 20 viviendas o 15
ó 10 entendéis el problema por mucho que
se legalice un suelo es decir que se
permita la construcc
y la oferta de viviendas continúa
estando muy restringida y por cierto
esto también explica muchos de los casos
de corrupción que tenemos en españa
la mayor parte de escándalos que estamos
descubriendo en los últimos años vienen
porque un constructor pagaba un soborno
al concejal de urbanismo para que en
lugar de tener un permiso para construir
diez viviendas le dieran uno para
construir el doble en otras palabras que
en el sector de la construcción existe
un incentivo perverso para que se
invierta en cosas como sobornos en lugar
de en cosas como esta otra
[Música]
anclados en el siglo 20 a que no
adivinan cuál es el sector menos
productivo de la economía exacto la
construcción hablamos de un mundo donde
lo raro es que los proyectos se terminan
en la fecha en la que se había previsto
y esto no sólo ocurre en españa' para
que os hagáis una idea las nuevas
oficinas de apple en sillicon valley se
terminaron dos años más tarde de lo
esperado y tuvieron un sobrecoste de dos
mil millones de dólares extra y lo mismo
ocurre con casi todas las viviendas que
se construyen hoy en día
según una encuesta de un estudio de
arquitectura británico el 60% de sus
obras se terminaban tarde y os
preguntaréis por qué las empresas de
construcción son tan poco serias la
respuesta está en que apenas han
innovado en las últimas décadas por
supuesto las casas de hoy en día son
mucho más modernas tienen mejores
sistemas de aislamiento y de calefacción
pero el modo en el que se construyen
continúa siendo el mismo que hace 50
años cualquier otro sector económico ha
avanzado mucho más por ejemplo una
fábrica de coches de hace 60 años no se
parece en nada a una fábrica de coches
de hoy en día
de los puestos de trabajo que tenían
nuestros abuelos han sido sustituidos
por máquinas y robots programados por
ordenador el resultado un automóvil de
hoy en día tiene muchas más prestaciones
y además es más barato de producir que
hace 60 años gracias a eso ahora casi
todas las familias se pueden permitir
uno o incluso dos coches sin embargo si
viéramos una obra en los años 60 apenas
no teníamos diferencias con lo que se
hace ahora
los mismos albañiles las mismas grúas
las empresas de construcción apenas han
invertido en innovación y esto es
comprensible si tenemos en cuenta que su
margen de beneficio es extremadamente
bajo habéis oído bien una promotora de
viviendas puede tener unas ganancias de
entre el 2 o el 5 por ciento por
supuesto que cuando hablamos de millones
de euros un 2 por ciento es más que
suficiente para hacer rico al dueño de
la empresa pero algunas penas permite
invertir en otras cosas como
investigación y desarrollo y valor de no
más de 300 millones de detalla
y no sé qué hacer con ello y tengo mi
barco que lleva 2 horas de navegación y
por si esto fuera poco los incentivos
para sustituir trabajadores por máquinas
son bastante pocos veréis a diferencia
de otros sectores económicos no es
necesario tener ninguna formación para
trabajar en la construcción y esto se
traduce en una mayor concentración de
mano de obra poco cualificada así que
podemos ir haciendo un pequeño resumen
por un lado tenemos que la oferta del
suelo está restringida lo que hace que
los precios de las propiedades suban
como la espuma después la construcción
de la vivienda en sí misma es un proceso
largo caro e impredecible
el resultado pues que las viviendas en
españa tienen unos precios prohibitivos
y sin embargo casi el 80 por ciento de
los españoles es propietario de una
vivienda cómo es esto posible pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
dinero para todos existe un principio
básico en economía las cosas valen lo
que alguien esté dispuesto a pagar por
ejemplo si un piso de cuatro
habitaciones en un barrio normal de
madrid vale más de trescientos mil euros
es simple y llanamente porque hay gente
que lo puede pagar pero cómo es posible
que haya tanta gente capaz de pagar
tantísimo dinero no se supone que españa
está en crisis no habíamos dicho que el
salario medio de españa es de menos de
dos mil euros al mes pues mis queridos
amigos de visual político la respuesta
está en los bancos
[Música]
trescientos mil euros es una auténtica
fortuna para alguien que está cobrando
un salario medio pero si todo ese dinero
se paga en cómodos plazos durante varios
años es un poquito más fácil verdad y de
cuánto tiempo creéis que estamos
hablando diez años veinte años pues lo
cierto es que hablamos de muchísimo más
hipotecas a 40 años un producto
exclusivo para jóvenes y con condiciones
habéis oído bien 40 años en españa no es
raro encontrarse a gente que tiene
hipotecas a 40 años y alguno dirá pero
en algún sentido es decir imaginad que
sois un banco y le concedes un préstamo
a una pareja para devolver en 40 años en
cuatro décadas
pueden ocurrir mil y unas razones por
las cuales no puedan devolver más el
dinero entonces dónde está el negocio
cómo es posible que un banco se pueda
arriesgar tantísimo al conceder un
préstamo la respuesta está en los bancos
centrales
[Aplausos]
el banco central europeo continuará
imprimiendo millones de euros para
impulsar la eurozona hasta 2019 tal cual
como lo es
europa tiene hoy más masa monetaria que
nunca y sin embargo a la vez tiene una
inflación relativamente baja
en otros vídeos de visual poli y os
hemos explicado que cuando los bancos
centrales primen billetes todos los
precios tienden a subir sin embargo en
europa pasa todo lo contrario porque
pues porque todo ese dinero recién
impreso va directamente a los bancos y
los bancos lo utilizan para que
efectivamente para dar préstamos eso
explica que con unos salarios
relativamente bajos la mayoría de los
españoles estén dispuestos a pagar
auténticas fortunas por tener una casa
en propiedad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y lo que es peor que el precio pueda
continuar subiendo hasta el infinito
siempre habrá alguien dispuesto a
conceder oa aceptar
hipotecas a 40 años en otras palabras
que todos los factores apuntan a que a
largo plazo las viviendas son cada vez
más y más caras y eso explica cosas como
estas
se dispara la rentabilidad de la
vivienda como inversión estoy seguro de
que lo habréis oído decir mil y una
veces invertir en ladrillo es una
inversión segura todos sabemos que no es
del todo cierto pero seguro que todos
conocemos a alguien que invierte sus
ahorros en comprar casas es decir que
junto a la gente que necesita comprar un
piso para vivir tenemos aquellos que lo
compran para invertir dicho de otra
forma los bancos centrales inflan la
demanda y después los ayuntamientos
restringen la oferta conclusión las
casas son cada día más caras y por
cierto tengo que hacer un paréntesis
para dar las gracias al estudio de
arquitectura de miguelángel fonseca por
haberme ayudado a entender todos los
detalles del mundo de la construcción y
el urbanismo
-miguel ángel fonseca es uno de los
mayores expertos de arquitectura
sostenible de españa y le podéis
escuchar todos los jueves en el programa
hoy por hoy en cadenaser valladolid os
dejo más detalles en la descripción del
vídeo
[Música]
así que ahora llega la pregunta de este
vídeo como creéis que se solucionaría
este problema habría que restringir las
hipotecas de los bancos tendríamos que
liberar el suelo para que se pudiera
construir qué tipo de políticas
solucionaría en este problema
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios pero antes de que os vayáis
esperando un momento porque tengo algo
muy importante que contaros este 17 de
febrero voy a dar una charla en el
evento de dix malagueta en málaga
[Música]
contaros una historia que os va a
encantar sobre el lobbies supervivencia
política y entretenimiento para adultos
los que viváis en málaga y alrededores
tenéis una oportunidad fantástica para
venir a verme a mí y a otros ponentes y
como os podéis imaginar para los
suscriptores de visual político tenemos
un descuento muy especial del 10% sólo
tenéis que comprar vuestra entrada en la
web de decks malagueta puntocom e
introducir la palabra visual política en
el código de descuento y os ahorras el
10% de verdad que es un evento que va a
merecer mucho la pena y tengo muchísimas
ganas de veros a todos en persona así
que ya sabéis el 17 de febrero
nos vemos en málaga en el evento de
decks malagueta y como siempre no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle al like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto